retour en france la sécurité sociale
alors que la situation est de plus en
plus préoccupant que le déficit
devraient cette année atteindre 10
milliards de francs le cnpf examinera
demain un rapport de son vice président
yvon chotard sur une réforme de la
sécurité sociale
où en est la sécurité sociale le point
jakin collins le déficit de la sécurité
sociale est un mal qui n'est pas nouveau
mais qui va en s'aggravant
il était de 4 milliards et demi en 1976
il pourrait atteindre neuf milliards
cette année
il faut se rappeler que la sécurité
sociale est divisé en trois départements
l'assurance maladie-maternité
l'assurance vieillesse les allocations
familiales le premier étant le plus
important des trois puisqu'il représente
à lui seul la moitié du budget total la
caisse d'allocations familiales qui a
été longtemps excédentaires est
seulement en équilibre depuis les
récentes augmentations des diverses
prestations familiales la caisse
vieillesse est elle aussi en équilibre
elle le sera bientôt plus parce que le
nombre des bénéficiaires est le montant
des retraites ont augmenté avec
l'égalisation des divers régimes
vieillesse les charges de la sécurité
sociale augmente régulièrement au rythme
moyen de dix huit et demi pour cent par
an les dépenses de santé ont été 2 72
milliards en 1975 et 2,82 milliards en
celle de l'assurance vieillesse de 35
milliards 7 en 75 et 2 47 milliards six
cent soixante seize les allocations
familiales de 34 millions en 1975 41
millions en 1976 en face de ces dépenses
les revenus n'augmentent pas la même
vitesse et au contraire à cause de la
crise économique
la masse des cotisations a diminué avec
le nombre des cotisants et les
difficultés de certaines entreprises à
payer leur dû alors que faire pour
réduire ce déficit de la sécurité
sociale
on peut soit réduire les dépenses mais
la qualité de la santé est devenue une
exigence des français difficiles à
changer
d'ailleurs le ministre de la santé n'y
est pas favorable et défend avec force
son budget on peut augmenter les
recettes
on pourrait alors majorer les
cotisations des employeurs c'est
difficile en raison de la crise et des
difficultés des entreprises de plus la
répercussion de ces majorations pourrait
faire augmenter les prix ont pour
augmenter les cotisations des salaires
les syndicats s'y opposent formellement
considérant les cotisations actuelles
suffisante
on peut réduire les prestations mais les
français supportent déjà assez mal le
ticket modérateur de 25 % qui reste à
leur charge et on voit mal comment on
pourrait revenir sur les avantages
sociaux récemment accordé aux plus
défavorisés faire des économies sur la
gestion de la sécurité sociale c'est
certainement faisable mais il ne faut
pas trop se faire d'illusions sur
l'importance des résultats ainsi obtenus
reste la possibilité pour l'état de
combler le déficit
il devrait alors trouver des recettes
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire avoir
recours à l'impôt si l'on veut diminuer
le déficit de la sécurité sociale le
gouvernement devra choisir entre ses
divers remède
parce que s'il y avait un remède miracle
il aurait déjà été appliquée il est
probable qu'il faudra en combiner
plusieurs pour arriver à une solution
acceptable